So, I've already showed you one convention
that we use when we simplify terms. We put
the constant factors at the beginning of
the term. When we do that, it makes it
easy once we simplify because we end up
with one coefficient and then all of the
variable factors after it. People also
tend to put the variable factors in
alphabetical order. So, if you wanted to
do that, we could say that this also
equals 30rst. In order to make the change
from 30srt to 30rst, we had to remember
the commutative property of
multiplication. Since we were allowed to
switch the order of r and s without
changing the value of this term. So, the
order that variable factors are written in
is just another convention in algebra.
It's just something that's useful for us
to use, but it doesn't change the fact
that this version of the term that we had
initially is mathematically equivalent to
either of these other two simplified
versions.